okay so with shongxi being released on
disney plus i thought we'd do a big deep
dive on the film and point out all the
easter eggs hidden details and call
backs to the comics there will be heavy
spoilers so if you haven't had a chance
to check it out then i highly recommend
that you check out now if you enjoy you
would massively appreciate the thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this each and every day without the
way welcome to the heavy spoilers show
now let's get into shengqi okay so we
open with a flashback to the early days
of the 10 rings with when we were
leading the charge the flag of the 10
rings is notably different to the one in
iron man 1 which is where the
organization was first introduced into
the mcu if you look closely you can see
that they've swapped out the swords for
the hooked weapons the followers used
later on in the movie the symbols on the
flag from the bottom left at the bottom
right mean majestic strong powerful
might or authority might power strength
strong robust and greatness all of which
are mantras of the group now the ten
rings group are an original creation but
they take clear inspiration from iron
man's greatest comic bill in the
mandarin and also the ten rings
themselves back in the day we were very
excited that these ten rings could
literally lead to the introduction of
the mandarin but we got one of the
oddest deviations from the comics in the
entire mcu in the movie wen wu is of
course chongqi's father but his dad in
the comics has a very difficult history
as originally he was fu manchu this was
a literary figure created by sex romana
who's now viewed as one of the most
insensitive cultural stereotypes of all
time often played by white actors on
screen marvel's studios wisely decided
to deviate from this and changed his
parental figure from fu manchu into enwu
in the source material they eventually
renamed fu manchu to be a character
called zheng zhu and they changed up his
western wife to gl league who was shong
chi's mother now he was introduced to
shang chi's father in the comics which
was made to capitalize on the boom in
martial arts movies at the time zheng
had an organization called the five
weapons society and like him their name
would change over time now in the movie
we learned the 10 rings have existed for
thousands of years but it's unclear if
the ones from the original iron man were
his group as that film takes place
during wenwoo's retirement now i
mentioned that wenwu was a composite of
chongqi's father but his identity is
also merged with the classic mandarin
from the comics of course the mandarin
was introduced in iron man 3 is a made
up figurehead for aldrich killian which
he used to strike fear into the public
the front man for this was trevor
slattery who acted as a patsy and
interestingly in chongqi we learn how he
was tricked into thinking it was a bbc
production and this ties into slattery
being from jolly old england now as for
the ten rings originally in the comics
they were created by a race of
dragonlike aliens called the mcluhans
and they crashed on earth millennia ago
the mac luins are the same species as
finn fang a giant dragon humanoid from
the comics who is somewhat referenced in
the great protector that appears later
on in the film the rings are changed up
to be worn as bracelets whereas in the
comics they were originally just rings
however due to their size it is possible
that they could be rings for the mac
lewins but that's just all guessing at
the moment and we know what happened
with our mephisto fan theories now the
movie plays koi with their origins but
where they came from is teased in a very
cool post-credits scene that will likely
lead into some sequels in the comics
each one of them has their own powers
and these include things like a mana
rearranger an impact beam vortex beam
disintegration blast black light white
light electro blast ice blast flame
blast and mento intensifier now the
movie simplifies this a lot and instead
makes them pretty much just bangles that
all work together they are inspired by
the real life iron rings used in martial
arts and these have been featured in the
legendary movies 36 chamber of shaolin
and kung fu hustle interestingly kung fu
hustle can be seen on a poster in
shanghai's room tying this all together
so that it's all connected now in the
flashback we learn that when woo became
an almost alexander the great like
figure whose kingdom stretched across
the entire world searching for more
power he ventured to tao lo a place
introduced in thor issue 301 in the
eternals kingo actually mentions that
thor used to follow him around all the
time when he was a kid so it is possible
that we might get some more nuts to this
in his future movies now this is
actually one of the highest god realms
and it's home to the xi'an thor went
there to help revive the asgardians and
he found people that were more than mere
mortals the race is powerful and strong
being immune to things that would kill
most humans in the comics taro even has
a pocket dimension adjacent to earth
much like what we see in the movie it
also seems like they might be combining
elements of kunlun which was a mystical
city from the comics that only had its
entrance open up every 10 years you
might also know it from the show iron
fist and whether that's going to remain
canon or not should be cleared up after
spider-man no way home now during his
hunt for tallow when we meet seong-chi's
future mother which is an interesting
change up as fu manchu originally sought
out a western woman so that they could
have what he perceived as the perfect
biological child however this was
retconned and his mother was changed to
jailing a woman who disappeared into the
negative zone
here his mother is a guardian of tarlow
and in that fight we see two distinct
different styles where wenwu is
aggressive and hard with his fighting
whilst ying li is graceful and almost
dancing it's reminiscent of yin and yang
an ancient chinese philosophy that
explains two opposite forces that are
complementary to each other this is
exactly what we see and sheng chi only
found himself truly when he learned to
mix his father's rage and anger with his
mother's calm and graceful nature the
two combine to make the perfect
offspring and it's clear why shang chi
is so balanced now as well as sheng chi
wen wu also had a daughter called xu
xiao ling and if you thought the
backstory of wenwy was complicated shu
gives him a run for his money shang has
had many sisters over the years in the
comic books and there was zhang bao
formerly phallo sue who was initially a
loyal servant of her father she would
later go on to become the leader of her
own organization which matches shu
creating her fight club that we aren't
allowed to talk about here now it seems
like marvel did pick and choose as he
also has a sister named esme who became
angry at him for abandoning the five
weapons society the colour of shu's suit
later in the movie matches s mace as
well and she also used daggers although
they weren't on a rope like we see with
shu now another sister was zheng shi hua
aka sister hammer and shinshan were
raised at their father's compound
together after this intro we cut his
shang as he lives his life as shown in
san francisco weirdly depending on what
country you're in can depend on what
posters you get and we can see in this
image that there's an outcast poster but
their album stanconia however in other
versions this is removed so i don't know
what andre i love you 3000 did but he
must have been a bad boy to have this
dropped out in some places along with
the kung fu hustle poster you can also
catch one for the godfather which is a
movie about the son of a crime boss
taking his father's place in the family
business after a period away from it
sheng was seemingly allowed by his
father to move to america for 10 years
so that he could live his life and see
the world it's similar to the comics
where chongqi would complete his first
assignment and also disappear but
instead of moving to america to go to
school and be called gangnam style he
would work with mi6 and dennis nyland
smith to bring down chongqi's father
gangnam style is a song that comes from
korea and it may be an odd to have seemu
made his name on kim's convenience a
show about a korean store where he was
one of the only actors who wasn't
actually korean we catch him as he works
with his best friend katie as a car
valet and katie is an original character
that likens herself to jeff gordon aka
the legendary nascar driver the pair are
incredibly similar and both have amazing
talents and potential but they choose to
squander this this is something which is
a theme for the movie as when we want
his son to fulfill his potential just
like katie's parents want her to be more
than a valet driver juxtaposing this
their childhood friend outgrew their fun
lifestyle and now views them as not
living up to what they're capable of
next they go to a karaoke bar and sing
the mega hit old town road by lil nazex
now because of this we know one that nas
wasn't snapped away as the song came out
in 2019 and two that shong and katie
weren't snapped as they know it quite
well considering the people that came
back earlier that year shongxi also
wears an eagle 17 shirt which was the
air between the snap in the blip hinting
that he survived i would also presume
that wenwoo wasn't snapped either as his
organization was still very strong in
2024 the blade is referenced by posters
outside showing blip sync and a support
group which is similar to the one that
steve attended in endgame getting some
reaching in but blipson could be a nod
to nsync as everyone said bye bye bye
now we get a good look at katie's family
and her grandmother honors her late
husband by saving him a place at the
table she clearly accepts his death
which is the opposite to when woo who
will do whatever he can to get his wife
back katie's mother is pushing towards
her going down a certain path which is
also murdered in how when were parents
this is actually known as tiger
parenting and it harkens back to the
ancient philosopher confucius i was
really hoping that the twist in the
movie would be that shong actually
killed katie's grandfather and then he
had to reveal this at some point but
alas that's gonna remain fanfiction for
me now on the bus we have some very cool
moments as it travels through san
francisco which was also the setting of
ant-man and the wasp we can catch the
actor there who asked peter parker to do
a flip in spider-man homecoming and i
love how this character gives a
breakdown of the fight it's a better
breakdown than most of the crap on this
channel so yeah go subscribe to him
instead of me now shang's past comes
back to haunt him as his father's
lackeys come for the necklace that his
mother gave him he's confronted by taser
face so sorry razorfist and we see the
amazing fighting and choreography in
action he fights whilst taking his
jacket off and this is an homage to
rumble in the bronx with jackie chan who
had a similar move now speaking of racer
fist a deleted scene provided more
context of how he came into wenmu's
employment and this was given a lot of
depth by interviews with the actor he
said there were plans to show how
razorfist was taken off the streets by
wenwu and raised as one of his forces
this differentiates from the source
material as in the box he was introduced
in master of kung fu 29 and employed by
colton velcro however the brothers
william scott and douglas scott shared
the mantle and were employed to hunt
down chongqi now another one of the
lackeys of wenwu is the death dealer
death dealer was introduced in comics
master of kung fu 115 and his real name
was lee chang lin he was a double agent
working for fu manchu and was only in
the comics for a short period of time
just like the movie
shout outs eric boss and rock stars for
pointing out that one of the screen
names watching the video was
anti-darkness which could be a nod to
agatha hawkness initially i was about
unsure on this but in one division we
also had an easter egg that said
anti-a's kitty litter and agatha
referred to herself as auntie quite a
lot i also found it hilarious how it was
auntie a's kitty litter as just like
kitty litter she was full of [ __ ] now
chungchi's necklace is taken from him by
razor fist and you might notice that
throughout the fight that he constantly
tries to grab his neck it's actually a
bit difficult to spot exactly the moment
that he grabs it but if you pay close
attention you might be able to follow it
when shong jumps between the buses you
can see that it's there and when
razorfist slams him against the window
we can see it hanging razorfist then
grabs his neck and then his wrist and
it's during this time that if you look
closely you will see that the necklace
disappears from this point onwards so
razorfist did it in the split second he
managed to grab his neck which is some
amazing attention to detail now one of
the best parts in the movie was the
scene on the plane in which xiang
explains his life story to katie he goes
over how he changed his name and also
its pronunciation now this could be a
reach but it could also relate to a
tweet by simu in which he gave life
lessons on how to pronounce each
character's name when the movie was
first announced many people pronounced
it shang instead of zhong so i think
this might be poking fun at that too now
his name also roughly translates to mean
rising growth of the spirit this is
superbly accurate for the movie version
of this character as he was stuck in a
rut after being done with his dad's
brutal and punishing nature we learn how
busy shong's sister has been in her time
away as he and katie head to her
fighting tournament at the golden
daggers club this name is actually a
reference to the secret group shang's
half-sister zhang bao led in the comics
later we learn how when we actually
wanted them both here as a way to have
them in the same place at the same time
so that he could announce his arrival
this is probably the most dense scene in
terms of easter eggs and we see the
undercard fighters which include helen a
widow from black widow we still have
zero insight as to what happened to
drakov's agents post black widow and it
seems like after the snap that the
characters fell on hard times and went
to fight for money she's going
head-to-head with an extremist user
which is a further nod to iron man 3.
they also appeared in agents of shield
but hey is it canon or not we don't
really know at this point now the main
attraction is a fight between
abomination and wong it's unclear as to
why these two are hitting each other but
we know from infinity war that wong is a
bit light on cash for tuna melts so
maybe after winning this he can finally
afford something from the deli now
what's most interesting about this is
that it's revealed they're just sparring
and that they actually have somewhat of
a friendship after they fight they head
through a portal and though we don't
know where this is it looks like it
might be the raft before this movie
released we heard in agents of shield
that blomsky abomination was in a cryo
cell in alaska so he could have been
moved to the raft we never see him being
recruited by val but i definitely think
that he was reintroduced so that they
could tease towards a big thunderbolts
or dark avengers feature so far val has
recruited a wish.com captain america
elena balova and now we have someone
who's basically an alternate version of
the hulk abomination is supposedly going
to appear in she-hulk which is where we
will learn more about him and to me it
is evident that we're getting a new team
that's going to replace the avengers as
well as this blomsky in his abomination
form looks far more comic book accurate
and he has fin-like ears that pull from
the pages of marvel xiong ends up
fighting and behind him we can see the
flag from madrapura which many people
thought might actually be captain
america's shield it's beyond me as to
why they didn't put this entire scene in
madrapa especially as we had it featured
in falcon in the winter soldier and most
of macau in the movie was done digitally
so i think they could have easily
changed things over xu xialing doing
this entire thing does call back to the
comics in some ways as xiang's sister
did try and create an organization to
rival their fathers which this fighting
tournament seems to be doing it's also
possible that it was made to find people
suitable enough to take on the 10 rings
and there's a lot of theories that can
come from this if you want to dive deep
enough now it's not long before their
father's forces attack leading katie to
hilariously sing hotel california as her
destruction technique on the surface
it's a simple song about staying at a
beverly hills hotel but it goes a lot
deeper than that don henley the lyricist
and vocalist has now said it's a song
about moving from innocence to
experience which is pretty much a
journey that sean goes on throughout the
movie throughout it both he and katie go
from wide-eyed valets to becoming adept
at their skills after experiencing a
side of the world that they didn't know
about there's also a lyric about how you
can check out at any time but you can
never leave which sort of mirrors how
xiang left the ten rings but he was
unable to truly leave as his father kept
a close eye on him we then moved to the
fight on the bamboo scaffolding which is
absolutely stunning the use of bamboo
instead of metal piping is a popular
alternative in the east and it was used
to build the great wall of china now
this fight scene actually reminds me a
lot of one of the ones from rush hour 2
in which jackie chan also traverses
someone battling against the forces of
rikitan at this point we see when we use
soldiers using the same weapons that are
on the 10 rings flag also a nice little
touch is how the weapons flow with the
same energy color as wenwood's 10 rings
possibly explaining how they have such
advanced tech as he may have used them
to power what we see we catch just how
powerful chongqi is as he fights his
former trainer the death dealer who we
spoke about earlier in the video he
almost kills the villain before his
father intervenes and the group are
captured but it shows just how far he's
come the compound is a james bond
villainesque location hidden away in the
mountains and you might also catch the
ten rings logo on the helicopter pad as
it lands at the base when we discusses
the mandarin as he talks about the power
of reputation and also names as
previously mentioned trevor used the
name to cover for killian but in some
ways killian using the name also helped
to cover for wenwoo as people attributed
stuff to aldrich even if he carried it
out now when we also name drops two
things that he's been known as namely
warrior king and master khan the former
is simple as he would have been at the
front as we saw him leading the charge
at the start and he would have no doubt
have become a king the latter master
khan is an iron fist villain who traded
and occult items from china it sort of
puts in place the idea that when we was
actually different villains from other
marvel titles and it would be great if
we learned that he'd been behind a lot
of things as we get more characters
introduced into the mcu after the worst
possible family reunion the intrepid
bunch head downstairs and find trevor
slattery reciting macbeth now if you
haven't seen it the marvel all hail the
king one shot bridges the gap between
iron man 3 and chongqi after first
showing up as a bonus feature on the
thor the dark will blu-ray it's now on
disney plus and it shows trevor slattery
being sent to seagate penitentiary after
the events of iron man 3. you may
recognize this location from luke cage
and we learned that justin hammer is
also alongside him in jail i kind of
pray that hammer returns for armor wars
as we need some of those amazing dance
moves back in the mcu now trevor was
kidnapped by an agent of the ten rings
played by scoot mcnairy and here in the
movie we learned he was about to be
executed but they loved his rendition of
macbeth he recites a passage where
macbeth has killed a man named duncan
and the guilt gets to him macbeth is
fitting as it's a cautionary tale of
power corrupting and also the fall of a
kingdom which are two things that happen
with when woo also with the die hard
thespian and liverpool fan is morris he
is what's known as a dijang in chinese
mythology and he's fond of singing and
dancing due to having no head these
creatures constantly run around in a
state of confusion so it's quite fitting
that there's one with trevor as they all
escape to try and get to tow low we see
razorfist's keyring and also another one
that's named butcher this could be a nod
to a marvel's comic villain named
butcher or maybe razorfist swap that
blade out for a butcher's knife reaching
as always now the crew escape and we
hear a hilarious discussion about how
trevor wanted to be an actor after
seeing planet of the apes he couldn't
understand that the apes were unreal and
they bust through a maze to tallow and
come into contact with mysterious
mythical creatures this is after heading
to a water portal which looks very very
similar to ones created by the sling
ring we also see a nine-tailed fox
horse-like beasts with dragon faces
which are known as lanma and food dogs
which look like giant lions here we
learn about the movie's true villain
which funnily enough is not when woo and
it's actually the dweller in darkness
the villain first appeared in thor 229
and is one of the fear lords who as you
guessed it gains power from the fear of
other people one of the other fearlords
was the evil nightmare who i hope
appears in the mcu if we don't get my
boy mephisto we learned that it was
imprisoned by the great protector and it
has soul eaters who resemble uh the
color ka
kala kulu the creator of the fear eaters
he is also a fellow fearlord and the
introduction of all this i hope is a
setup for more scary and creepy villains
in the mcu now we learned how chong's
mother was killed by a gang looking for
wenwu this was by the iron gang who in
the comics are affiliated with fu manchu
this led when we want to creating a
mission for his son which was to kill
the last iron gang member this is
actually similar to comics where shang
chi is given a mission to kill someone
and like what we see this made him run
away now cutting back to tao lo i really
like how the scales from the predator
are used to create weapons which are the
only things that are able to kill the
soul leaders it's also used to make
xiong and his sister's costumes which
are very much like the comics with his
sisters being similar to esme's from the
source material the fight between son
and father is absolutely superb and it
felt a lot different to the other mcu
battles the rings are used quite a lot
and shong takes off of them and manages
to change the colour symbolizing he has
taken on his mother's great protector
power his father seems at peace that his
son is grown as a person and then
decides to sacrifice himself the way
that the souls are taken out also looks
very similar to how dr strange supreme
took the souls and what if the day is
saved and we have katie and xiong
mentioned to their friend about their
journey of self-discovery before they
can relax though wong returns seeking
out chongqi and kenny which sets up the
post-credits scene now here we get an
appearance by captain marvel and also
bruce banner who's back to his human
form
none of them know where the rings come
from and it doesn't match chittari or
cree technology hinting at it being tied
to an alien life form that we don't know
about yet you can also see that bruce's
arm hasn't healed which makes sense
considering how broken thanos was after
snapping and then destroying the stones
seems like he may struggle once more to
summon the green beast from within and
we know that going forward we're going
to be getting an adaptation of world war
hulk potentially bruce could try to
unleash the beast and this could lead to
a massive battle between him and the
avengers now how he got back to normal
we don't know but in avengers end game
we watched as they create a way to push
time through scott so they may have done
this with bruce though his arm would
have been healed i actually prefer there
being two sides of the hulk being
something that the character battles
over and hopefully because of this
change we get new iterations of the
character such as joe fixer and devil
hulk down the line it's mentioned how
something has awoken from the signal
which could be the mcluhan's could also
be galactus an eternal or even a lost
fantastic four member which would make
sense if we've already had a multiversal
secret war it is incredibly tough to
gauge considering chongqi has
essentially been given an original story
here and there's so many directions that
they could take things it could also be
finn fang fume who was notably absent
from this movie i think he would make a
great villain for a sequel in the other
post-credits scene we see shia ling take
over the ten rings which has been her
aim from the off behind her we can see
that the ten rings flag has changed once
more and this shows that the
organization is now under completely new
leadership the idea of her sitting on
the throne watching her fight his train
of course calls back to earlier in the
movie when when we was in a similar
position watching his do the same thing
if we play the clip side by side we can
see how she's taken over his empire in
several ways and it's such a cool scene
to end on and with that we also end our
video and of course love to hear your
thoughts on it in the comments section
below we are running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of zack
snyder's dc trilogy on the 30th of
november and all you have to do to begin
with the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the movie we
picked the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the eternals which will
be linked on screen right now we go over
the full plot of the movie and it's
post-credits scenes so definitely go
head over there right after this if not
then thanks for sitting through the
video i hope to see you on the next one
and you have a good weekend take care
peace